Boyd's in Dallas welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Boyd better than I deserve
what's up I'm in a little bit of a
situation hoping that you were able to
help me so my girlfriend and I paid off
all our credit card debt we live
together we have two children together
however I am in a collection agency for
a car rental that was in an accident
with my mother and it's $15,000 and she
still has student loans seven thousand
dollars in student loans and a five
thousand dollar college tuition that
still needs to be paid now we paid off
all our credit card debt the thing that
I'm confused about is which way to
attack this we have about seven thousand
dollars in savings that's including the
$1,000 emergency fund which I do want to
separate that I just don't know what's
the best account to put that in and also
I just want to pay off as much debt as I
can but we're driving a 2002 Chevy Tahoe
right now that heats up gas and I was
looking at maybe get a more reliable car
you know I'm not sure if I should use
the money in the savings to do the
reliable call no no you need to you need
to quit buying stuff and you get on a
tight budget and you start working your
way through these deaths which you've
been kind of doing the problem the
problem I have in helping your advising
you is you're trying to live life as if
you're married when you're not and you
know that leaves you in a legal
predicament because if you pay off her
stuff with your money or she pays off
your stuff with her money there's no
recourse there's no way you can make a
whole mom right now
I know but it still heard that because
you're not married and still your debt
because you're not married she's not got
any problems with that $15,000 rental
car company you do
you've not got any problems with her
student loans
she does the only problem you've got is
is you're trying to live this marriage
thing out that and not be married so
it's gonna be very difficult to work
this through but let's take a stab at it
and let's see if we can get some things
going number one on how long ago was the
$15,000 wreck with a rent-a-car company
April of last year and why did your car
insurance not cover it well my mother
had crashed a week's car that we have
and she crashed the car that she was on
the policy for but then when we rented
the rental car I rented the car for her
and the gentleman at the office told me
as long as she's on my insurance that
she's allowed to drive the rental car
and once she's going to her second
accident within a month she was supposed
to sign the papers and I didn't find
that out until after she crashed the car
so I mean it's a he said she said thing
I don't lie to calling lawyers and get
lawyers they know I mean you have
insurance you rented a car for your
mother and she wrecked it twice after
she had wrecked a car that you had
gotten her before once this woman can't
drive good lord
okay so I'm guessing she's broke yeah I
mean my stepfather is gonna try to pay
it off but I don't I don't know what
happens if we don't pay it your name is
on this her name's not on it and correct
and that's what's stressful about it
they're not coming after her you're
right they don't come after you and oh
yeah you're gonna get sued for $15,000
if you don't settle this I would offer
them $6,000 a settlement and full film
you're broke I offered them seven and
they said they couldn't do seven and
that they could do they could only take
off two thousand which would come off to
thirteen so I don't know if that's just
like you know become tougher and stick
with my number and you don't have a
choice you don't you don't have 13 yeah
you know a choice so what I would
negotiate with them then is to be
to pay them payments yeah I know that's
what that's pretty much where that
that's going yeah just say I'll I'll
start paying you 200 bucks a month until
I get this paid off I don't have any
money and so I can't pay you okay and
then you use the other money you have to
start cleaning up
I assume the money that's in the savings
account was put there partially by your
girlfriend yeah okay so that could be
used partially to pay off some of her
debts because you're only debts this
$15,000 debacle right yeah that's the
only thing I mean we paid off the credit
card we were real happy about that and
we said oh I did that but we're not
really a student loan debt you know
$15,000 debt to the record company
correct you know that
so yeah you what do you make a year I
started a new job six months it's it's
performance pay I do active I do
HVAC so it's a VHD in Texas how do you
make and my busy season is now I made so
far year-to-date 40 mm great
so you're on it you're on up in six
months you're on an 80,000 $9,000 your
pace yeah I'm hoping that continues I
mean I love what I do I'm really good at
it no you're working hard I do I would
get the every dollar budget app it's
free online and sit down I started using
it and I just I haven't used it to the
best of its ability because I what I
really wanted to do was pretend that I
only make $1,500 every paper you know I
wanted to pretend that I only make
$3,000 a month no you need to print in
you make what you make and put it on
paper and tell every one of those
dollars of what to do but you're what
you're saying is the same thing and that
is the household needs to be on beans
and rice rice and beans coupons
we don't go out to eat we're not going
on vacation we don't do anything we have
a mess we have student loan debt we have
this crisis where there's creditor this
rental car companies getting ready to
sue us we got to get them paid off and
the good news is making 90 you can clean
up 15,000 pretty quick you know like
five six months you know you can pay it
off
and then you can pay off her stuff if
you want to pay off her stuff and not be
married to her not what I recommend but
you know you can work a sideways thing
on this and maybe you get a little money
out of your mother maybe I wouldn't bet
on it oh don't do that stuff